if they cannot in bounce them all just  call the timeout holder Tatum hit the  rim on the Miss intentionally loose Paul  Brown for the tie by the back door they  were knocked it away new 24  [Music]  Tatum on the blow by beautiful could've  also hit a foul tough shot by worse  talented Russ with another highlight in  off-balance shot like this he gets  fouled he got the bump right there and  then he bangs it in hit him when they  hit it out block by Tatum it's a three  on one Hayward with delay other come on  that was a incredible defensive play  terrific block talk about Tatum's  offense defensively he's improved as  well harden got all the way to the cup  see that was too easy  Tatum started by Harden  into theis that lambs at home  you gotta make a move yeah pulls up on  tuffet then step back on the way for the  game theis with the loose ball and they  won't get it off Houston rides into  Boston and wins it 111 110 in overtime